how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
cinematic universe
since the unfortunate passing of
chadwick boseman many fans have been
wondering what exactly marvel studios is
going to do
with black panther t'challa for a long
time it seemed like the marvel fan base
was a little bit split
with some fans not wanting marvel
studios to recast t'challa
out of respect for chadwick boseman
while others think that the black
panther legacy should live on
and that they should recast t'challa
because he's such an important character
but now marvel studios has officially
commented on what their plans are
moving forward with black panther as a
character and
black panther as a franchise i wanted to
acknowledge
the devastating loss of a dear friend
and member of the marvel studios family
chadwick boseman was an immensely
talented actor and an inspirational
individual
who affected all of our lives
professionally and personally
his portrayal of t'challa the black
panther is iconic and transcends any
iteration of the character in any other
medium from marvel's past
and it's for that reason that we will
not recast the character
however to honor the legacy that chad
helped us build through his portrayal of
the king of wakanda
we want to continue to explore the world
of wakanda
and all of the rich and varied
characters introduced in the first film
writer director ryan coogler is hard at
work on the sequel now and will bring
the film to you in theaters
july 8th 2022.
so straight from the president of marvel
studios they will not recast
black panther t'challa however they are
still making black panther 2 and as
kevin feige said they are going to
explore other characters in wakanda that
were introduced in the first
film now just because t'challa is not
returning does not mean that there's not
going to be a new black panther wakanda
will most certainly name a new black
panther
of course that title will be up for
challenge just like we saw in the first
black panther film which will add for an
interesting take in black panther 2.
shuri is technically next in line for
the throne but as kevin feige mentioned
they're going to explore other
characters from the first film
this means that umbaku is going to be
back and perhaps he feels like he might
make a better black panther than shuri
would although shuri has been black
panther in the comics before
there is also the chance that marvel
could just decide that shuri is going to
be the black panther and umbaku will
respect the fact that t'challa is gone
and let his sister be the new black
panther but there's also always the
possibility that killmonger could come
back somehow
it's the marvel cinematic universe
people who are dead don't
always stay dead there are many
different ways to bring characters back
to life in our universe
or they could even make it to where he
never died perhaps off-screen they give
him a heart-shaped herb and he lives
it's unsure right now but if they are
going to explore characters from the
first film he would be a very good
character to bring back
and it would also be really cool to
learn about the other tribes of wakanda
so embaku may be getting a lot more
screen time in black panther 2 than he
did in the first film
i think this is definitely a great
respectable move by marvel
honoring chadwick boseman not recasting
the character but
let me know what you think about
marvel's decision in the comments down
below
don't forget to subscribe to stay up to
date on all the latest mcu news and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a tony stark
quantum suit funko pop for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
bye